only fans isn't like a great restaurant
that you go to right where you're like
hey dude you gotta try this only fans
that I had that I tried last week
want to thank our sponsor fitbod look
you're not the same person as you were
at the start of the year so it's natural
for your fitness journey to have ups and
downs whatever or wherever you are in
your fitness journey get the most out of
every workout with fitbot get 20 off
your subscription at
fitbod.me DPT that's
f-i-t-b-o-d dot m e slash d p t hey
townies welcome to another episode of
dumb people Town population
dude welcome to the show all the way
from New Zealand you flew all the way in
just to record this and you're flying
all the way back afterwards immediately
yeah
I wish we could pay for you we added in
the budget we had the points really but
we had the points to get you here and it
was worth it it was weird that you
demanded first class and then settled
for business class right right but I
still think that's I'm glad you're here
you know I'm very happy to be here and
I'm excited to go back to LAX the best
support in the world the calmest the
comments no traffic getting in and out
I'm not in such a good mood most updated
the worst yeah the worst well you're
coming from New Zealand uh what's the
plan are you are you heading off to
Montreal from here or yeah yeah so I'm
I'm here for a couple of days trying to
like reset myself [__] leg wise yeah and
then get on a plane and go to Montreal
do JFL Great Festival Galas and stuff
like that yes shows and and stuff so
much do stand-up comedy as they say is
that what it's called yeah have you been
to Montreal before Oh yes I have I've
been to Montreal once when I was 12
years old to visit my dad's best friend
and it was snowing and uh freezing yeah
it was freezing like this doesn't happen
in New Zealand stuck in a house with my
dad so you're just stuck with like two
Persian guys two older I shouldn't call
my dad elderly older older than you
that'd be a great Point talking about
like car prices
uh very geographical recommendation go
to a sandwich place called pave p-a-v-e
pave you will love it do you know what I
love about the United States of America
among many things sure
yeah I love I love America for many many
reasons and I genuinely do I know I did
a gag about bad things but I genuinely
love America but the thing I love about
America the most is you is sandwiches oh
my God I mean there's you guys love we
just did a whole deal podcast about not
a podcast whole thing but what went on
here so we went on a riff with our last
guest who was who is in here just about
mid-level sub shops Rory skull and I
have a podcast we have the we got a
letter once halfway through the letter
we talked for Sam with about sandwiches
for 20 minutes and then realized we
never finished the letter you are so on
you we are seeing you we have been seen
by this it's such a thing that's it it's
such a thing I mean look it is such a
thing but Jay and I were just talking
about being in San Francisco on this
last podcast too and between the comedy
club and the bar that's like on the same
block they opened up this Curry House
that was
like the Hawaiian dish uh
yeah it's rice and then a hamburger
patty and then egg and then egg on top
this is like you've never had this it's
a Hawaiian dish so my daughter makes
misuvius
oh my God but I saw someone do one as a
burrito so I guarantee somebody's done
Curry sandwiches yeah Curry sandwich has
to but the the smells coming out of here
were so good chicken sandwich it was
like you know in a cartoon when like the
smell comes down Tikka stop it
that's probably what it's called those
private place is called
uh chicken Rogue
roll up yeah all right so you know like
cartoon characters they get the scent
that something beautiful and their feet
get lifted
I thought they was going to do that in
like a finger under your nose all right
so here's the deal the world is dumb and
I'm sure it's really down in New Zealand
too I'm sure you've all experienced this
no it's Dumber over in Australia but
fine all right way Dumber in Australia
than New Zealand yeah
Australia take that Gold Coast okay all
right how many other places do you know
take that uh Perth take that Bondi Beach
yeah okay you got oh he knows more take
that kangaroo Island Is that real yeah
it's a real I went there take that
lizard Island take that cans take I can
keep going that's really impressive
spider Fields I'm just gonna name
dangerous things in places and I imagine
that's the name
who killed the cow by the way there are
broken glasses our friend Eric went to
Australia and he's like well for the
first time and he read he was like
reading up about the country he's like
um there are 8 000 things that could
kill me oh yeah Australia is a dangerous
place it's just straight up
spiders dudes with mullets like it's
okay we got that too though we got that
too we do have that too okay okay name
places in New Zealand New Zealand uh
okay Auckland uh Queenstown yes Dunedin
what's up Christ Church uh Christ Church
I'm not even go there I went to the
Amish field Winery okay I've been to
places uh Mr Shire
yes
so here's the naming place
all right so can I get in this story
because the world listen it's dumb I
mean we could just goof around all day
no no we've got dumb stories to get into
all right all right so here's that it
was brought to you by uh Derek the
legendary daddy at games design dude so
he sent this into it thanks brother
appreciate this I wonder what he does
for a job uh I think he's like works at
a Curry House a curry sandwich house all
right it definitely does not design
games like that's not he's like a
misleading guy all right so here we go
woman considers calling off engagement
after cousin gifts her fiance a
subscription to her adult video content
huh can you follow this Pax do they say
that again okay so it would be like I
had an only fans right which maybe I do
yeah and only dance
my cousin cousin married your cousin was
getting married my cousin's getting
married and my husband gives my cousin
no his cousin woman considers she didn't
do it she considers calling off
engagement after cousin gifts her
fiancee so this is what I was saying
okay you guys
or
it gave my fiance a subscription to mine
this isn't well written not you're only
fans too to her only fans so it's my
yeah my my
wife's cousin yeah gives me a
subscription to her only fans so it's a
little risque because the cousin's like
here's my gift for your wedding my gift
for your wedding your fiance a
subscription to my only sitting on a
computer yeah I mean it was on the
registry yeah like today we put it on
the list guys we have the gravy boat and
we have the video of her shooting ping
pong balls out of her vagina that's
awesome we got the great we got two
gravy boats both of those
subscribe to an only fans is intense
I'm not shaming you or King shaming you
but that is intense
the guy's like you said I could sign up
for stuff he makes it about you told me
to participate in this wedding you you
wanted the extra lay Crusade why would I
get off the wedding for somebody else's
actions she's considering well if I even
consider it it's it's highly did you ask
for it well it's highly dependent on how
he interacts yeah I'm now I'm now going
to explain another thing that she's mad
a woman is considering ending her
engagement after her cousin quote ruined
Christmas
by gifting her fiance a subscription to
only fans this is also in a vacuum this
is hilarious right it is like if you
were if you were like the John Mulaney
character in episode six of the bear
season two yeah where you are just a
person who gets to observe this family
if that was your role at this person's
Christmas
in it right so he also has a comic you'd
be like you guys this is the greatest
thing so in a post to the true off my
chest subreddit this woman explained how
the situation went down and how it left
her entire family feeling deeply awkward
in the interposed she describes how she
comes to form a very large comes from a
very large fiance comes that sorry
that's a great Point
how she originates from a very large
family with lots of cousins in their 20s
and 30s who all exchange gifts so this
is a family that has a lot of cousins
and everyone is a white elephant what
does that mean it's a white elephant we
would have all the gifts let's say you
went first you don't you don't know who
bought what you only know the thing you
bought so you pick a gift that isn't the
one you bought right you open it now
before we start to argue with me let's
just roll with what I say you open it
you can either you you then have to keep
it because you went first I then go
second I pick a gift I open it I can
either take your gift oh right and now
you get mine and then so on and so forth
there's so many variations basically
what it is it's a surprise present first
this is a curse where you can either
keep what you have or trade for
something else can you if you pick so
maybe she put in an envelope that said
congrats you want my subscription
if you pick fifth can you take first yes
yes oh my God now some people play let's
say I'm the fifth person or fourth in
this and you guys have already all
opened yours right whoever and I go
before I grab one I can say I don't want
to grab a new one I want Randy's so I
would take Randy's now Randy doesn't
have it so Randy can either take from
there or he could take someone else's
you just can't take back the one that
was just taken from you oh that's so
maybe she just put an envelope down that
was like hey who wants this free free
you know you know
all right so one of her cousins Anna
found an easy gift solution for all the
men who were married to or dating the
family member a family member only fan
subscriptions the bride-to-be witnessed
her fiancee received one of the cousins
gifts in a pink envelope which that's
hilarious uh in the shape of a taco that
was weird just kidding and uh quickly
hide it uh in his pocket so he opens it
wasn't just getting it it was open it oh
okay and then quickly hide it in his
pocket
um later her cousin Rachel pulled her
aside in disbelief at the only fans gift
that turned out to be on the inside of
the envelopes after her own boyfriend
said it made him feel uncomfortable but
when the bride-to-be asked her fiance
about the gift he lied about it okay I
mean this is this is about trust now
yeah
right there's a whole other you can't
lie who was uncomfortable
he's like nothing 1 000 the guy who said
that I'm uncomfortable about this is
also using the only fan exactly
yeah you handled it yes honey I feel so
uncomfortable about this and he's and he
says the whole website four times the
more he says it I'm so uncomfortable why
would she give me a free thing with the
password
I mean the password is this this and
this why would she do this disgusting
who has his password that is this this
this he's recording a voicemail
oh
I wish we had an actual password I don't
even know how only family Gary got all
right fight so do you need it
none of us know how only I don't do you
need a password I'm asking Dan it's like
Netflix okay yeah no no it's a patreon
yeah you patreon yeah you subscribe yeah
they're doing comedy on only fans yeah
they are a lot of comments like people
are getting paid to do sets yeah I do I
do naked comedies
[__] emotionally naked
but when the bride okay so he lied about
it so when she told him she saw him both
receive the gift and put it in his
pocket she says he quote suddenly
remembers he got the gift oh yeah but
said he had but he then said he hadn't
opened it he is digging such a hole for
himself dude dude that turned out to be
a lie when she took the envelope out of
his pocket it already
dude she's considering calling off the
wedding
yeah I mean this is I mean some people
freak out under pressure yeah like don't
rob a bank with this guy because yeah
don't roll a bank oh yeah so after
catching other people say there's a
phrase like she's my ride or die yeah
like she'll ride yeah is that a phrase
in New Zealand she's my ride or die man
we know what it is but we know or
something you are for a thing you're my
writer yeah this guy is just died he
will not ride he will take you down he
will make everything will die around him
that ride or die means like we have to
hear that I'm there to the end for you I
I'll ride Bonnie and Clyde I'll ride or
die for craft spirals mac and cheese
go to the ends of the Earth until you
ride a die for curry sandwiches there
you go that's it
so goddamn good all right so after
catching his fancy and like the bride to
be then went to confront Anna about her
inappropriate gift and that's when
everything thing got even more Awkward
let's go other family members confront
our cousin about the gift cards too she
found Anna so what she found Anna
embroiled in arguments with several
other Bad Business friends yeah I didn't
do a discount code and it's the only
Fan's cousin yeah
that's right you had to get the
information called her out for gifting
sexual content to their boyfriends and
husbands but Anna insisted it wasn't a
come on the bride to be writes what Anna
claimed quote she's just trying to get
her business off the ground and by a
business of the ground it basically
revolves on around her being on the
ground her gift is not sexual it's just
marketing this [__] she's saying this
to people what's non-sexual after a
heated argument the bride-to-be left the
family Christmas party with her brother
and his husband because several of her
family members assisted she apologized
Dana if you are trying to get it off the
ground you give it to the gay couple too
am I right yeah spread it around spread
it around she handed her story but she's
good at spreading I'm seriously
considering calling off the engagement
over this and I'm pissed at my cousin
for ruining both Christmas and my
relationships now most commentaries so
I'm the [__] yeah most common wait it
is really kind of most commenters agreed
that Anna's adult gift was way out of
line several commenters were dying to
know what the bride to be had said to
Anna because they felt uh they would
have been even angrier than she was one
user Road not gonna lie I want to know
what you said that your mom wants you to
apologize to your aunt for because I
would have been ruthless so whatever she
said to her right made her mad enough to
leave with the gay cousins but like you
know how like when someone is in the
wrong and they then get onto a thread of
what their argument is yeah and then
they just start saying that louder and
louder so you know like people were
confronting this woman at the party and
they were like you said what to my
boyfriend she's like I'm just trying to
get my business off the ground I'm it's
not sexual it's marketing like it's all
could be true like she might just be an
idiot right right it was like I don't
care if they ever look at it I just need
more
if she's giving free subscriptions to
people she's not going to be making
money so also oh yeah exactly that's
what I said that's why it's bad business
yeah also only fans isn't it's only fans
the type of thing you know like only
fans isn't like a great restaurant that
you go to right where you're like hey
dude you gotta try this only fans that I
had that I tried last week yeah it's not
a thing that you like share or recommend
that you spread around yeah you know
like if you want dude Instagram is free
yes just do what everyone else does and
be naked on Instagram thank you yeah
thank you the user went on to warn the
bride to be about red flags this
incident received about you know her
fiance the lies in gaslighting when you
saw him not
I don't know if he was gaslighting he's
just gaslighting if he said he didn't
get it right he said he didn't open it
and he's trying to know if I think
that's just a lie it's not like he's not
saying you didn't see me get it yeah
he's saying I didn't get he's trying to
get out of it yeah it could be he could
have freaked out but he pocketed after
opening okay so should I mean there's no
ending to this except should she get out
of the engagement I'm curious to hear
what each of you think based on all of
this I say this a lot
show me the pattern this is like like if
this is an indicative pattern of the guy
then be like hey how about you don't be
a [__] idiot again he's like I will
not and then if you get that pattern
again but it's not like he's going on
only it the cousin really started a lot
of this the customer is the only part
that I don't know I I think people can
watch porn and experience their own
sexuality and incorporate porn and to
their relationships anything can be
healthy anything can be unhealthy that's
right so the only issue for me is that
most of the time when people you know
you see people joke about it somebody
just did it at tag it I think they were
talking about their hall pass you you
your hall pass is never a person you'll
ever be in the same hallway closeness
right it's that's what I'm saying that's
making it that's what I'm saying right
because he's gonna like if she thinks
that they're gonna go through their
marriage and he doesn't look at naked
women on the internet right forget it at
some point like this do not get married
be alone it's the fact that they can be
in the same house multiple times what
you said she could have given every
single person a pink vagina Taco shaped
envelope and said uh it might be
unconventional but I I am trying to grow
my business if you guys want to
subscribe to me don't ever tell me that
you looked at it or maybe she's like
tell me look I don't care what my point
is is then it would have been like
everybody could have been like you are
nuts versus like why are you just trying
to get people who are going to interact
with you and presumably heterosexually
lean that way because I feel like that's
what she wants to only fans too that's
supposed to actually become this is my
cousin's husband coming over here who
wants to see any a cousin husband
right what if that becomes your only fan
it's like yeah the Christmas party
hookup your husband get to the white
elephant in the room I I I I am most
untrusting of the cousin because I just
don't think it's a legitimate reason
again to give them you don't you don't
handle like she just might be dumb yeah
she might be dumb like you don't like
she might you always have to say when
someone pisses you off you first have to
go are they dumb are they dumb yeah what
is their mouth a lot of times I'm like
was that person dumb or being an [__]
the intent and this is what we say on
this show a lot of times yeah intent is
everything in terms of how hot you come
in on someone intent is everything like
if she's dumb and doesn't get it then
you School her if she's really trying to
do something nefarious all right fine
you can go after your cousin needs to
understand more and your fiance needs to
say I [__] up that's right right I
would love to see someone with an only
fans just like putting pamphlets into
people's litter boxes
are at the airport at the airport bark
like they do for comedy shows come on
out come on open this up I open myself
for you good first story first story a
lot of dumbness in it uh Dan you got the
Second Story uh pack Society is with us
he's coming to us all the way from New
Zealand fantastic comic there uh New
Zealand people know him hopefully this
podcast and you being on this will open
us up to a bunch of New Zealand fans
yeah and open you up to a bunch of
Americans yeah both ways I hope so I
hope so I am relatively success um I
keep saying relatively like I shouldn't
say relatively you are success
I own a thousand square meters of land
oh my god there you go yeah is that a
lot is a thousand square meters
three meters to a foot good that's good
it's good yes yeah a thousand square
meters is good in New Zealand fantastic
you know I drive an electric car
Universal signature range is the stuff
they're like is this wait this came to
us out of date
it's on the show it's expired how is
that possible all right uh more with Pac
Society Danny got the next story we'll
be right back with more dumb people down
right after this
hey guys welcome back to the show I
jumped me on that one hey guys welcome
back
hey guys welcome back to let Max do it
one more time hey guys welcome back to
dumbland town and you're in for a great
uh show of love thank you dumb land
we're here in dumbland it's not people
town uh pack Society is our guests what
do you got going on uh we'll tell you
what we got going on so uh
superscars.com is our uh website where
you can see all of our tour dates and
stuff we're gonna do we're probably
gonna do a tag it in the middle of uh
which we explained to you this show our
friends do sets and then we are writing
tags of jokes that we pitch them on
stage afterwards we're very
collaborative very fun check The Comedy
Store just check our uh superscars.com
but we'll be in Ann Arbor Michigan uh
September 8th and 9th we'll be in the
comedy fort in Fort Collins uh uh
October I'm around fifth or sixth and
then Springfield uh Missouri cool new
spot cool new spot the Blue Room uh
that's happening in November like the
night the 10th and 11th or something
like that so good stuff we just did our
show live the two-man show one-man show
that we did in LA and we're very excited
yeah that might happen before the end of
the year at a theater we'll see we'll
figure it out anyway that's that uh Pax
people how can people like find you
follow these folks follow you and all
that stuff uh pack Society everywhere
just Pak Society p-a-x
a-s-s-a-d-i on Instagram on Facebook do
people still go yeah people's mom
everyone's moms yeah moms I'm into moms
I would guess within a year you'll be
back here in the states and people
should come check you out at some shows
if you want yeah yeah please you should
I hope
um I I want to start doing more stand up
in La I haven't done much stand up you
should you absolutely should and if we
can help in any way yeah let's figure
that I mean two and I have a show if
you're ever in town when that's
happening oh yeah they have a great show
all right Dan let's see the story okay
guys this is presented by Matthew
Friedman at not your average man so our
fans just so you know we have a bunch of
fans that always send in stories and we
have it in our timeline on Twitter where
like who was the first person to send
this in we can find it out we give
credit a handful of people so Matthew
Friedman is a regular he sends it a lot
of stories so we appreciate man yeah
thank you also if you're a member of our
patreon it's only five bucks you get a
whole bunch of fun personal Shenanigans
from us and old dumb news stories and
you can send in a story from your own
dumb life where's matthew Friedman from
do we know we don't know I don't know if
it's not average it's not he's not your
average man all right ready he's from
Florida man loses pants while being
chased by cops in hours-long Manhunt
hours so he ran out of his pants I guess
I mean at some point where your pants
like isn't that fast it's quite fast so
fast he runs out of this quite the night
or the pants were that big you're like
dude it's like you know he's wearing
like jinko jeans from the 90s and
they're just too big or or he gets
chased by cops often and he just always
has rip-off pants
Breakaway sorry break away no you don't
want the resistance the rip-off pants
are great because in that case he's like
they won't recognize me even you know I
still have this haircut in this face
yeah as soon as I rip these yeah like a
different prescription doesn't say his
[__] out no that's right new pants new
man so break away or no pants
as Pax calls them are really you know
you see them in like basketball long
time yeah
it feels very 90s too it is very 90s but
the game is about ready to start let's
rip these things off so what if that for
him was his thing of like this
do you know what I want to do I want to
go to a pickup basketball game and just
have regular pants on and just force rip
them off but not take your shoes off
serious who brought this guy to the game
all right but not have basketball shorts
underneath
covering him and everyone's like uh you
got him not that crazy guy we're not
doing man-to-man we're going to do a
Zone that's flagrant a suspect lost his
pants while he was being chased by
Florida police but kept the Manhunt up
for hour hours longer completely in the
nude oh my God he must have started no
shirt you must have started no shirt he
was dying no underwear or he paint lost
the pants and was like I'm not gonna
Winnie Pooh this so then he just went
police responded to a home in Brantford
on July 2nd to a residence where Jesse
lamb uh-huh Gainesville
was reportedly refusing to leave
according to Suwanee so Gainesville over
the University of Florida yeah so it's a
big sort of college where Tom Petty's
from yeah when I think Florida I think
people on those boats with the big
propellers on the back like
Louisiana
that's your swamp life a friend of ours
who is a reporter for uh the Boston
Globe and then has now gone on to like
make a bunch of really interesting
documentary films that Freddie Origins
who went to college with he did a
documentary film about the Society of
people who are on those huge fan boats
who live in the Everglades and how like
they can just do whatever they want back
there because cops will not go yeah they
just won't go back in that area because
they're like you will get shot and
killed and then you will just disappear
yeah right because they know how to like
just disappear and feed you to the
alligators and that's it yeah swamp is
the best place to hide a body let's do
it absolutely agreed
we've got two shows that the swamp on
Friday at the swamp no guarantee there's
a club called The Swamp Jesse lamb or at
least an ALT music venue of Gainesville
it was reportedly refusing to leave the
house according to the Suwanee County
Sheriff's Office while cops were on
their way they learned that lamb had an
active warrant out for failing to appear
in court in 2021 Court driving with a
suspended license okay sure it starts
with that when cops arrived at the
residence they spotted lamb sprinting
out the back door that's a compliment
from the back of the residence toward
the SUNY River in nothing but a pair of
shorts deputies chased him until he
jumped in the river and began swimming
towards a floating dock which he hid
under so under the dock also as you know
and you I know you know any body of
water in Florida has alligators it's
dangerous I don't care if you're driving
by the side of the road and there's like
a little I don't know just like a
drainage ditch yeah there's an alligator
in there just assume there is one in
there if you if you if you go into your
bath at your house yes you look first if
you have a tall glass of water on there
this is a full-size alligator an adult
your pet's dish your pet's drinking dish
yes
he hit under the dock officers demanded
that lamb come out I love that you think
a guy wearing one article of clothing
who swam into alligator water and in
another doctors get out and he's gonna
respond we have demand she's like so do
I sir we can see you under the dock oh I
should see you too [__] like that
don't forget me yeah officers demanded
that lamb come out from below the dock
he did but swam away again that's sort
of a prank right that's kind of a prank
okay and I'm gone kind of a good gag
it's a great gag Dan do you think he
swam with swimming away again is like
three sport athletes how fun how
athletic is this guy this is like a
criminal Triathlon he's he ran a little
yeah he swam a little yeah
Jesse's Michael Phelps yes he told
deputies that he was surrendering the
Michael Phelps of meth yes right oh this
sheriff's office anytime they can throw
in Shade that's like accurate but also
like sure right this is quote from the
Sheriff's Office Jesse Jesse told
deputies he was surrendering but we
already know Jesse's not a man of his
word since he promised to show up in
court in 2021 I didn't that's now you're
like a scorned lover yeah exactly you're
gonna bring that surrender but we all
know what that we're gonna bring that up
yeah as you swam away lamb lost his
shorts and quote was now skinny dipping
as he headed towards another Dock and
hid below it she's the Goldilocks of
ducks Goldie docs just right Goldie
docks is what his name is like for the
next couple of hours police played hide
and seek with Jesse look at he probably
never had a dad okay and this is his one
yes engage with someone else
he's just trying to connect with another
male with an older male figure right
mentors be my father figure please hide
and seek with me he played hide and seek
with Jesse his head would suddenly
appear from below the dock only did it
disappear again this guy sounds huge he
does right he sounds adorable just
adorable this is when you know that like
too much of the neighborhood is involved
because the cops aren't getting it done
police said a neighbor then stuck an
underwater camera below the dock that's
like some neighbor who's been waiting he
hasn't drone and he has an underwater
camera and he's been waiting I got it I
got it he's like he literally no one
says anything and he pops his head out
he's like someone said they need
surveillance right shut up shut up Susan
I've got this they need me someone needs
me I know you know he said back to his
wife and you didn't want me to buy it
oh you said the underwater camera was a
bad you didn't want me to buy the
underwater cow just like how many years
now I'm probably gonna get a goddamn
metal for this
they might make me a deputy right you
know what Susan I am going to buy those
Bush cameras
you know what this camera can't see you
in my future
unless you're underwater you want me to
get both of them I got two so the camera
the neighbor sticks an underwater camera
below the dock confirming he's still
under there which is also somebody he's
still there he's still under there and
you could hold a stick with a mirror at
the bottom of it he's still there Sam
eventually made a break and made a
beeline for the other side of the river
but was captured in his birthday suit by
a deputy with the assistance of the dock
owner now this guy's helping out he's
like I'll help you out in the dock
owners please do not help out he was
transported to the Suwannee County jail
he's charged with resisting arrest
without violence to without violence and
failure to appear oh my God I will ask
you guys now how old is Jesse lamb
just to confirm this is naked guy naked
guys
naked swimming under the duck you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna
zag and I'm gonna go
59.50 I think what I get I get the vibe
that he's like one of those weird like
weirdly strong old guys yeah you know
when you come across a weirdly stronger
guy and you're like you've done
something he's not going he doesn't want
to go back to jail right he doesn't want
to go back to exactly doesn't want to go
back to it's he's the type of guy where
you go what do you do for a living and
he goes import export right no that's
like whatever you know that important
important
he's like I do important important
shouldn't there be an extra part of that
how do you make money the second one's
important
report import that's funny both of your
things are important and this is a very
key element about this guy very leathery
skin Oh yes yes like so peeled back and
leathery totally like he's never put on
even just uh the tiniest drop of
sunscreen never never right uh I think
he's 37 37 37. so still good I like that
still good water treading age exactly
right this could be a guy who wants to
be arrested like he's like I don't like
my wife I don't like my situation he's
got a guy's down in jail they don't
bother me all the time to do all these
not a house it's not a thousand square
meters but it's still a house it's not
I'm gonna say it's not an essential
Oakland suburb 37
26 26. whoa we're all over the map I
love the world that lends it to the
running yeah the running I'm just
running and swimming Jesse lamb get your
answers in now Tony's wherever you may
be and then we'll go on to Story number
three plus you'll get to hear my plugs
uh when we come back from the break
about my special 11 11. all right ready
Jesse lamb is
59 years
[Applause]
like if you told me that guy was 35 too
I believe yeah he's still a bit of an
ass kicker I just I just there's no you
don't do this kind of show unless you're
getting to the back end of your life
yeah you just don't care anymore right I
love that you got it right look at this
it's what a universal show this show is
uh all right that's uh that also sounds
like a fun place I mean it does if
you're trying to evade people yeah a lot
of activities uh Jay what do we got a
little taste of what uh Story Three is
uh don't ignore people's texts okay
that's a good thing to know good
information to have literally my
favorite thing right now it feels good
but they're a consequences pack Society
is with us and uh we'll be right back
with dumb people time we'll find out
what Dan's got going on right after this
town
look guys whatever your Fitness level is
or what your goals are fitbod love these
guys they build a dynamic workout plan
for just for you and it optimizes future
workouts based on your personal progress
yeah I'm using it I love it also you
know what it's great you tell them what
you you can like put in the equipment
you have like I have resistance bands
yeah and then you can get all of these
movements or exercises that maximize
what you have and that for me is awesome
because like when I went up to my cabin
I used it yes because it's so you can
get into these scenarios where even if
you want to like be active you're like
on YouTube links trying to find like
what somebody did and how they moved and
how do I use this what band is right for
this sort of movement everything is
right into the fitbot app for like where
you're at what you have and what you
want to do it's sort of like we used to
print MapQuest out and then we got
Google Maps that's right uh and then now
you we used to like kind of you know jot
down stuff that people would say or we
would read or whatever all in the fitbot
app which is so easy to use and it takes
the excuse out of not being like it's
too hard for me to get into this right
now it makes it easy so they even have
for me which I love is workouts that
that have no equipment it's just you and
your body weight and just using
different workouts for you in your body
which just to me I think is for us I
don't want to get injured it helps you
in those ways and to me super easy to
follow and then it tracks your progress
progress so that keeps you wanting to
come back personal bets and stuff like
that you can get all your charts uh
actually they have new movements that
you can do the right way with over 1400
exercise demonstration videos guys
wherever you are in your fitness journey
like Randy said up top get the most out
of every workout with fitbot you can get
20 off to zero percent off your
subscription at fitbod.me d p t that's
fitbod.me d p t we all need to get in
shape do it with fit button
[Music]
people town
hey guys welcome back to the show before
Jay takes us home and we uh do a little
more fun stuff with Pax uh Daniel tell
us what's going on for you guys you can
see me at the high plains Comedy
Festival in September I think that's
around the 20th 21st it is a great
Festival it's the best just such a great
hang and then October 20th I'm
headlining uh yuck Fest in Boston and I
am shooting my special recording my
album it's all happening at the same
time two shows 11 11 at the Lincoln
Lodge tickets are available right now
let's sell both of them out yeah
speaking of Boston is your story of the
guy backing the yeah of course car into
the spot in Boston in this special at
all I'm not telling you I'm just saying
this is one of my favorite comedy bits
it's so wonderful this is a brilliant
beautiful bit what about the betway you
karate kick a small elderly woman in the
chest first of all she dared me okay
if someone could tell that story and
make it funny wouldn't that just be that
wouldn't that be the greatest story ever
like because if it were any of us we
start by saying okay this is a story
where I kick an elderly woman in the
chest and yeah the end of this yes
name is Marjorie Taylor green yeah I
have a story where I punch a 12 year old
and I'm trying to figure out how to do
we'll help you with that oh my god
um so yeah 11 11 the Lincoln Logs
everything's at danielvankirk.com so a
bunch of whole other good things as well
I hope to see you great all right go go
to it this is sent in by at Derek
Shipley Derek Shipley is a regular he is
a
regularly yep he's such a good dude he's
such a good dude and here we go here's
the end line angry woman whoa accused of
damaging BMW after man ignores her texts
we'll see I will say when I text
somebody and they have red receipts on I
think they are so mature like I'm like
wow you're letting everyone know you
read this because you know you're gonna
write back right away yeah or you're
crazy yes and you don't care that people
have read it and haven't gone or you
want them to know you're not going to
respond or you want them to know they've
got it I just wish I had that comment to
know that I'll always write back right
away oh it's insane so you you if you
read it you gotta you gotta write back I
imagine if they have red receipts on
don't you think that they you only put
on red receipts if you if you want to
know you're going to get back I just IG
the joy I get from reading a text and
they're not responding is I'm the type
of person of power I'm the type of
person who likes to so like you know
when you're in a busy parking lot and
people are like circling they're trying
to look for a couple I like to get in my
car and turn my car on so my back lights
go on so if one thing and then I just
don't leave and then yes and then you
just scroll through and then I just and
then I just go and then I pick and I put
my phone to my ear as if I'm on a call
I'm not on a call traveler now and now
there's 13 people waiting two people
honking at each other because this guy
thinks he's in space and this woman
thinks it's her space yeah and you're
just scrolling and while that's
happening I'm reading texts and not
responding
angry woman was arrested after damaging
a rented BMW oh no it's a rental it's a
rental she paid an extra 11 bucks you
got the insurance after a man ignored
her texts and calls oh she bumped it up
to call and catch the nap a Eustis
police officer was dispatched Thursday
afternoon the 300 block of West Woodward
Avenue to investigate a report of a
damaged vehicle when the officer arrived
at the scene he found a man in the
driver's seat of a late model BMW what
does a late model mean late model means
it's older milder older
99.63 series it's not good the officer
saw this line in the cylinder right so
the man sitting in the driver's seat the
officer saw that the man was covered in
glass shards which appeared to be from
the driver's side so she busted the
window and he just sat there in the
shirts he's like oh I'm waiting for the
cops oh the cops are gonna cops again no
that's his dedication to ignoring her
right like even that he's like you're
not getting a response no reason do you
hear me do you hear me
he's just like the officer said the man
covered in glass shards there was blood
visible on the door inside window the
officer also noted in his report that uh
the windshield in the front of the
steering wheel it looked like it had
been punched all the way through oh my
god oh she oh so the blood was her blood
yeah thank you the victim told the
officer that how old janelli Macias
janelli makes cs34 I'll go Walter Brown
he's like a trumpet player thirty four
point time what age is somebody so
pissed off and crazy 34 Dan I'm gonna go
42. 42 49 her eggs are frozen and she's
beating now 49. she's just this is it
49.
uh with this thing uh get your answers
in janelli Macias is 26
she'd come to his workplace and was
angry that she came to his work that's
already a bad move yeah uh she came out
of red flags yeah she was angry that he
had not answered the texts or calls she
had made to him she said that he said
that she jumped on his back oh my God
he's like you've been on my back for the
last six weeks now we're just making it
official and he was on the east side of
the building and that he was able to
throw her off him make a funny Dan uh
then he got into his rented what year
BMW so we did try and de-escalate the
situation so here's to a woman who's
been ignored yeah his idea to
de-escalate is to get into a car and
ignore her and stay and stay you know
what Drive what year what year is this
car so you did say late model 2017.
2004. that's so good 2009.
late model they consider 2020. yeah wow
it either had to be if it's still rented
it can't be more intuitive I guess
that's right but I thought maybe it was
a turo situation so he locked he locked
himself in the car just to ignore her
more right which surrounded by Windows
right uh and he saw Macias run to the
back of the BMW and take the license
plate off has she done this before oh
she's calculated she knows what she's
doing and now start whipping networks he
retrieved the plate from her car and got
back into the BMW so she no she takes
the license plate like I'm taking this
as yours you'll have to talk to me now I
said fine he goes to her car gets the
license probably says nothing to her she
probably says that counted as a date
wait who's sending the girl's not
sending this in right no no the guy is
oh I'm sure the police okay this is
there no no none of the people involved
are sending this no but there are
stories they see and then they send her
to us at Daniel Brothers No for a second
thought this crazy lady was sending it
no oh my God
and our patreon people will send in his
stories of their own life
was I being weird to rip the lights
she had okay so he retrieved the plate
from her car got back into the BMW
rolled up his side window Macy's had
thrown her cell phone at him which he
tossed anybody who throws the phone
which he tossed out of the passenger
side window before locking all the doors
okay good maybe you haven't locked him
already no Macias jumped on the hood of
the car this is when you drive away
and punched the windshield and ripped
off the wiper arms from the BMW which he
had rented from Enterprise because his
personal car was being repaired he told
the officer that the blood came from her
hands you were absolutely right when she
cut them while attacking the BMW Macias
was interviewed by officers and said
that she had been tackled by the victim
but could not explain how that happened
nor could she explain her bloody hands
and the blood found in the damaged
Windows all she could explain is that
they're in love that's right he's not
texting me and my boyfriend over there
not her boyfriend not her boyfriend not
her boyfriend check your texts I sent
you two emojis that's what you're saved
as in my phone I don't control that I
don't you're saved as the one in my
phone you need to know that all right
Nancy this was placed under arrest for
criminal mischief and domestic battery
charge the cutest of all she was booked
at Lake County jail and released after
posting how much Bond we'll get out of
here on this how much money
five thousand dollars say ten thousand
dollars ten thousand dollars there's a
lot of damage
I'm gonna I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with
twenty five twenty five thousand dollars
okay I may have led you down the wrong
path she was released after posting two
thousand dollars that's not bad damn you
were right she's out and ready to
reconnect with this very special person
in her life I want to know how
classically beautiful she is I wish
there was a butter the hotter someone is
the more you'll allow the man or woman
the man or woman yes
not after a certain point in your life
yeah yeah punching Through a Windshield
then and what did she think was gonna
happen I want to punch this windshield
and get him back I could be like this is
it it's blind rage it's a person who
can't process their emotions that's it I
had a girl in high school paint me and
her
and a portrait of us naked hugging
after having one conversation with them
what and how long have you guys been
together and we are married
and I love her according to her and I
love her and I and you look right in the
camera and I love her
um no I we I I dated as a strong word
but I interacted with her intimately
yeah for like six months which is too
long yeah it's way too long after the
painting after the paintings
what was it you needed on a red flag I
mean come on they were young and stupid
I was young you were high school but the
thing is she was like the fourth hottest
person in the school see do you know
what I mean like when you get into those
talented artists you
no it's not fully developed I'm also a
skinny like half Pakistani half Iranian
kid who's like white girls are never
attracted to wait so this is a white
girl she's like here we go okay I'm not
talking about fourth hottest ethnic girl
I'm talking
about that at all which counts in the
same pool you guys have to say that but
if you're doing it for both Pakistan and
Iran I'm doing it for my people you're
doing it for this is essentially your
ending of Rocky for
I could change
a lot of people together but it was also
my ending of get out and sure
that was her way of saying get it out
let me show you this painting yeah
because now you would look at a painting
like even if a fan gave that to you
you'd go wow um yeah I do need to get
going yeah yeah yeah I had a guy give me
a um a basketball jersey and he'd
stitched on my name onto the basketball
jersey and stitched on like a fake
Sports to a fake basketball team yeah
and he was wearing the jersey at the
show and he was like we're on the same
team now man you're like well security
it's like I just want to wear your skin
for an hour you're like oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
was a great show packed Society you are
a friend of the show now you're our
friend now that's just it we go to New
Zealand we're hanging out yeah come over
anytime I'm about a thousand square
meters you've said that and uh for all
of our fans listening and watching at
home oh [__] we gotta get back to work
stick around make a sound there's more
to people town
[Music]